[Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  we're e17 weirdos and this is stay  another day ASMR style  today maybe if you glance along my way  don't think I can take it under stain  won't you stay  [Music]  oh don't like this don't you say is the  vine or kiss how'd you stay  [Applause]  [Music]  I touch your face while you are stealing  Diedrich solid solid it's solid eternal  good times we had  it's gonna be right here to stay Eric  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  stay now let's go  the packets and the baggie babe watched  a but now day yesterday letters were a  whisper into the world  Linnea  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Piko specific  tonight  [Music]  peace  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you